en esta ocasión quiero intentar resolver
la siguiente desigualdad la siguiente
desigualdad que dice x cuadrada más 3 x
+ 3 x esto quiero que sea más grande que
10 y bueno justo ahora es el momento en
donde debes de pausar el vídeo e
intentar hacerlo por ti mismo pero antes
quiero darte un consejo intenta trabajar
esta desigualdad como si fuera una
ecuación cuadrática solo que cuando
llegues al final reflexiona un poco
sobre lo que te está diciendo esta
desigualdad
ok voy a suponer que ya trabajaste esta
desigualdad y vamos a resolverlo para
esto lo primero que voy a hacer es
restar 10 de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad y me va a quedar a déjame
cambiar de color me va a quedar x
cuadrada ok más 3 x ok menos 10 menos 10
el signo de la desigualdad se conserva
se mantiene igual porque recuerda que
cuando yo restó o sumó algo de ambos
lados de la desigualdad la desigualdad
se conservan esto va a ser más grande
quiero que sea más grande que 10 menos
10 lo cual es 0 ok y fíjate que aquí
tenemos la expresión cuadrática la cual
por cierto podemos factorizar si nos
fijamos en x cuadrada más 3 x menos días
vamos a pensar en dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 10 vamos a
actualizarlo así y que se suman que su
suma me dé 3 positivo cuál es la pareja
de numerosos cuya multiplicación cuyo
producto es menos 10 y cuya suma es 3
positivo existirá pues pensemos un poco
en él
qué par de números multiplicando se nos
da 10 bueno puedo pensar en 10 y 10 10
menos uno no es tres y por otra parte
menos diez más uno no es tres tampoco
se me ocurre 5 y 2 5 por 2 es 10 5 por
menos dos es 10 y 5 menos dos estrés
positivo perfecto ya nos encontramos los
números son cinco y menos dos ahora ten
cuidado de que el menos quede al lado
del dos porque si yo pongo menos cinco y
dos positivos también me daría su
multiplicación menos diez su producto
menos diez sin embargo cuando yo me tomé
la suma me va a quedar menos 3 y en este
caso 5 x menos 2 es menos 10 y 5 más
menos 2 estrés positivo de lujo entonces
ya puedo escribir esta expresión de aquí
justo esto que tengo aquí de la
siguiente manera como
x + 5 x + 5 esto a su vez multiplica
esto que a su vez multiplica a x2 x
menos 2 ok
espera déjame ponerlo con el mismo color
a x2 y esto me dicen que tiene que ser
más grande que ese no ok ahora date
cuenta que si tuviéramos una igualdad ya
hubiéramos acabado el problema porque
está diciendo que tengo dos números
multiplicado igual a cero si fuese una
igualdad y entonces diría o el primero
cero o el segundo es cero y ya creaba el
problema sin embargo aquí tengo una
desigualdad
tengo dos números multiplicándose x + 5
x x2 que me tienen que dar un valor más
grande que es 0 y justo en este momento
es lo que me refería con que
reflexionarán aquí se refiere está esta
expresión que tengo aquí fíjate bien si
yo tuviera dos números
imagínate que tengo
lo voy a multiplicar por b voy a
multiplicarlo por b y esto esto a su vez
yo digo que es más grande que 0 a qué me
refiero con esto bueno si tengo a por de
más grande que 0
estoy diciendo que ambos deben de tener
el mismo signo porque si te das cuenta
algo positivo por algo positivo me da
algo positivo es decir algo más grande
que 0 o en su dado caso algo negativo
por algo negativo me da algo positivo es
decir algo más grande que 0 y eso es muy
importante es la reflexión que yo quería
que tú hicieras fíjate bien a por ve más
grande que 0 esto quiere decir que vamos
a ponerlo así ya sea y déjanos ponerlo
con otro color para que no nos
confundamos ya
que sea más grande que 0 ok que a sea
más grande que 0 más grande que 0 y a su
vez también ven y eso es muy importante
antes de ponerlo con este color y
también que sea más grande que 0 b
estaba el color rojo y ven sea más
grande que 0 ok ya sea que hace más
grande que 0 y veces más grandes que 0 o
en su dado caso o en su dado caso que
pase lo contrario que a sea menor que
cero que sea un número negativo sea
menor que cero y además que me sea menor
que cero y que b también sea menor que
cero es decir que ambos sean números
negativos o ambos son positivos
ambos son negativos y eso es muy
importante esto tiene que pasar para que
se cumpla esta desigualdad que tengo
aquí ahora regresemos a este caso que
estoy analizando si yo tengo que x + 5 x
x2 tiene que ser más grande que 0 estoy
diciendo que x + 5 es más grande que 0 y
x menos 2 es más grande que 0 o que x +
5 es menor que cero y x2 es menor que
cero y vamos a poner lo máximo para
tomar este mismo color para a y para x
menos 5 ok voy a ponerlo así que x5 que
x + 5 sea más grande que 0 y a su vez ok
vamos a ponerlo y a su vez x menos 2
también sea más grande que se ande
generando con color rojo x menos 2 sea
más grande que será ok que pase esto o
en su dado caso o en su caso
que pase que x 5 que x + 5 esto sea
menor que cero esto sea menor que cero y
a su vez al mismo tiempo y al mismo
tiempo que x2 que x menos 2 también sea
menor que cero también sea menor que
cero y estoy utilizando justo esta
información y estos datos que acabamos
de obtener justo aquí a la derecha o que
ambos son positivos o que ambos son
negativos y son las únicas dos formas en
que pase esta desigualdad que tengo aquí
ok pues vamos a analizar las dos con
mucha calma imagínate que yo tengo que x
+ 5 es más grande que 0 y x menos 2 es
más grande que 0 vamos a ponerlo así
aunque x 5 x + 5 sea más grande que 0 ok
y al mismo tiempo déjame cambiar de
color y al mismo tiempo que x menos 2
también sea más grande que 0 que x menos
2 sean más grande que 0 esto qué quiere
decir bueno de aquí podemos despejar a x
y podremos obtener qué
x es más grande que menos 5 y a su vez
estamos pidiendo al mismo tiempo estamos
pidiendo que x sea más grande que x sea
más grande que 2 lo único que hice este
lado fueron estar 5 de ambos lados de la
desigualdad y de este lado lo que hice
fue sumar dos de ambos lados de la
desigualdad en el primer caso en el
primer caso x es más grande que menos 5
y x es más grande que 2 que por cierto
estos dos los podemos juntar en una
misma oración un número que sea más
grande que menos 5 y un número que sea
más grande que 2 bueno en general son
los números que son más grandes que 2 si
yo tengo un número x más grande que 2 si
yo tengo un número que es más grande que
2 también va a ser más grande que menos
ahora bien date cuenta que no pasa lo
contrario si yo tengo un número más
grande que menos 5 por ejemplo el 0 el
cero no es más grande que 2 y yo lo que
quiero es que se cumplan
ambas desigualdades quiero los números
que sean más grandes que menos 5 y a su
vez que sean más grandes que 2 y por lo
tanto
únicos que cumplen esos son los números
que son más grandes que dos es decir de
estas dos lo estoy juntando y lo estoy
intentando en esta desigualdad que tengo
aquí ok esto es el primer caso que pase
esto de aquí ahora también tenemos un
segundo caso este de aquí y en el
segundo caso lo que me dice es que x más
5 o sea menor que cero voy a ponerlo
aquí x + 5 sea menor que cero y a su vez
que x menos 2 y a su vez que x 2
déjame que me dé color sea menor que
cero que x menos 2 sea menor que cero y
bueno y aquí puedo despejar de aquí
tengo ante x más 5 es menor que cero si
x es menor que menos 5 lo único que hice
fue restar 5 de ambos lados de la
desigualdad y a su vez y a su vez se
cumplan estoy buscando también los
números que cumplan que x menor sea
menor que cero esto quiere decir que x
sea más pequeño que 2 ok estoy buscando
los números que sean menores que menos 5
y a su vez que sean menores que 2 y si
te das cuenta esto de aquí
esto de aquí lo podemos sintetizar todo
esto en los números que son más pequeños
que menos 5 todo número que es más
pequeño que menos 5 es más pequeño que 2
pero ten cuidado de igual manera que
aquí a la izquierda no todo número que
es más pequeño que 2 es más pequeño que
menos 5 debes de tener cuidado yo lo que
quiero que se cumplan
ambas desigualdades simultáneamente es
decir imagínate que te tomas al cero
cero sería menor que 2 pero no es menor
que menos 5 yo lo que busco son los
números que cumplan
ambas desigualdades y bueno la solución
de ambas desigualdades son los números
que son menores que menos 5 y ya está mi
respuesta de este problema ya estamos a
punto de obtenerla son los olas x que
son más grandes que 2
las equis que son más chicas que menos 5
y esa es la respuesta
los números que son más grandes que
menos 2 ok o en todo caso los números
que son más pequeños que menos 5 los que
son más pequeños primero 5 y ya que
están aquí tenemos la respuesta ahora lo
que quiero que te des cuenta es que esto
de aquí lo podemos graficar en una recta
numérica si yo pongo la recta numérica
vamos a ponerle aquí arriba si yo pongo
una recta numérica por aquí ok
este es mi eje x este es mi eje x y
supongamos que este es el valor de 0 ok
por aquí tengo uno y por aquí tengo al 2
ok y de otro lado tengo aquí al menos
uno menos uno por aquí tengo al menos
dos ok por aquí tengo al menos tres ok
por aquí al menos cuatro y por aquí al
menos cinco mi solución de esta
desigualdad que tengo aquí con la que
empecé x
3x es más grande que 10 son los números
que son más grandes que 2 ok vamos a
ponerlo así son los números que son más
grandes que 2 y ojo es una desigualdad
estricta por lo tanto no toca el 2
entonces voy a poner un circulito aquí
más grandes que 2 son todos estos de
aquí ok y por otra parte tengo las x las
x que son más pequeñas que menos 5
entonces voy a tomar este color me fijo
en el -5 pongo también un circulito
abierto porque es una desigualdad
estricta me voy a fijar en todos los
menores a menos 5 todos los que van por
acá ok y bueno tú puedes corroborar que
esto realmente es cierto imagínate que
te tomas un número más grande que 2
supongamos 3 3 al cuadrado es 999 es 18
que es un número más grande que 10 eso
sí se cumplen estamos bien y también
podemos probar con un número más pequeño
que menos 5 se me ocurre menos 6 menos 6
al cuadrado es 36 36 menos 18 36 menos
18 es 18 que es un número
grande que 10 y ya está la solución de
esta desigualdad con la que empezamos de
esta que tenemos aquí es justo esta que
tenemos acá abajo